هذه الفكره تفتح الصفحات التاريخ الى
تاسيس الناتو في العام
1949 كانت هناك محاولات لاقامه تحالفات
امنيه اقليميه مشابهه في المنطقه لكنها لم
تنجح انذاك دول في اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
لمواجهه الخصومه الشيوعيين طبعا في دور
قياديا لامريكا ومنها الفلبين كوريا
الجنوبيه وحتى الصينيون القوميون ابان
حربهم مع الشيوعيين الصينيين وكذلك
استراليا ونيوزيلندا ولكن بقيت وجهات
النظر حول كيفيه تحقيق ذلك مختلفه هل
النجاح سيكون حليفهم اليوم ويتمدد النيتو
في شرق اسيا ستاتي يرى ان ما يحدث في
اوروبا له عواقب على شرق اسيا وما يحدث
هناك مهم لاوروبا ولذلك يجب ان يكون هناك
تعاون اقوى ومن اجل ذلك وخلال قمه مدريد
في يوني وعشرين حدثت امور تحدث لاول مره
كل من استراليا اليابان نيوزيلندا كوريا
الجنوبيه حضرت باول مره وفي وثيقه المفهوم
الاستراتيجي للحلف ذكرت الصين لاول مره
كما ذكرنا اعتبر الصين تحديا لمصالح دول
الحلف وامينها والصين وكوريا الشماليه
تنتقدان هذه التصرفات طبعا اعتبرت بكين
تصريحات ستمبر عوده لعقليه الحرب البارده
اعتبرتها مقدمه للحرب فهل يقع المحظور
فعلا
لا يستبعد الجنرال مايك القائد القائد
قياده الحركه الجويه الامريكيه خوضه حرب
مع الصين في عام 2025 ويتفق معه سياسيون
عنده ومن بينهم رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
في مجلس النواب الامريكي مايك ماكول